it's about time these disney favorites  got a glow up but this isn't just any  old makeover  it's a full-on star-filled  transformation  celebrities watch out these disney  characters are coming for your looks  and they're ready to take on the world  one beauty treatment at a time  you'll love watching these ladies and  gents get their glow on  courtesy of one seriously talented tick  tock artist  [Music]  [Music]  uh  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  which makeover is your favorite sound  off in the comments section to let us  know which glow up is the fairest of  them all  hit that like button to show your love  for these disney transformations  thanks for watching